Hey everyone James Murphy here, this
is mCoding, and let's just jump into
it with some controversial events
happening in the world of Python.
If you haven't already heard the news,
the CPython developers just pushed out a
breaking change to the language, modifying
longstanding behavior of how int-to-string
and string-to-int conversions work, putting a
default limit on how many digits are allowed.
Previously, there was no limit on
the size of integer you could use,
as long as you have enough memory to hold it.
This was one of the cool features of Python
that new programmers would often explore. Just
print math.factorial(10000) and there it is.
But if you download Python today,
instead you'll be greeted with an error
telling you the answer is too big.
The default limit is 4300 digits.
Users must now call this
sys.set_int_max_str_digits to increase the digit
limit or set it to 0 to disable the limit.
Now it prints just as before.
This limit only applies to conversions
from int to string and string to int that
aren't in a base that's a power of 2,
so printing binary and hex are not affected.
But humans normally write numbers in base 10,
so this does affect the most common use case.
Also note that this is not a limit on the
size of integers outright, only on
conversions to and from strings.
So you can still operate on big numbers without
any changes, you just might not be able to print
the results. That's why the error here is on line
4 where the print statement is, and not on line
3 where the answer is actually computed.
Part of what makes this so controversial was
that this change, which undoubtedly breaks some
existing projects, was pushed out with essentially
no warning to the community not just to the
latest development branch of Python 3.11,
but to Python 3.7, 3.8, 3.9, and
3.10 as well in a patch release.
Patch releases are generally meant to be
made of small changes that are completely
backwards compatible or that fix outright bugs,
errors, crashes, or security vulnerabilities.
As such, tooling such as automated test
runners may use the latest patch by default
and package managers may ignore the patch number
when considering version compatibility.
This means that projects depending on the old
behavior will have their automated tests broken,
and their users who are on the latest
patch will immediately start experiencing
these breaking changes, even if the
project hasn't made any new release.
So why would they push out a
breaking change like this?
Going to the CPython source, this GitHub issue
claims the previous behavior of int/string
conversion is a security vulnerability, which
explains why it was able to be pushed out so
quickly even though it was a breaking change.
This vulnerability was initially reported in May
of 2020 and officially went public on September
1, 2022, according to RedHat's CVE page,
although the GitHub issue was apparently
created a month before, in August.
So what is this vulnerability?
Well, CPython uses an N^2 algorithm
in the number of digits for int/string
conversions when the bases aren't compatible.
Here, a mere million and one digits
took 4.5 seconds to complete.
We can confirm this N^2 behavior empirically by
looking at the timing plots for conversions.
We can clearly see superlinear
growth in this plot.
And, if we look at a log-log plot and compute
the least squares fit we see that the estimated
power is very close to 2.
So, empirically at least,
this really is an N^2 algorithm.
Under the hood, the actual algorithm
that Python uses is very similar to
these basic conversion functions.
It's really not much more than repeated division
or multiplication depending on the direction.
These may appear to be just O(N) algorithms, but
it's actually O(N^2) because multiplication and
division are not constant-time operations since
we are working with arbitrarily large numbers.
So these divide-by-10 or multiply-by-10
are actually O(N) operations themselves.
This means that converting between integers
and strings is more expensive than you might
expect and it opens Python up to a
denial of service attack on any code
that tries to convert between them.
In particular, any kind of parser or API
that takes base 10 values as strings may be
vulnerable, including the builtin json module,
parsing libraries like Pydantic, and
API frameworks that depend on these.
A bad actor can send a moderately large number
with say a million digits to cause an API to
freeze for around 5 seconds like we saw.
The new default digit limit fixes this issue
by raising an exception that your code can
catch unless you have explicitly opted-in
to allowing this expensive conversion.
Of course, primarily in favor of the change,
there are operators and users of services
that have these vulnerable APIs.
The original GitHub issue argues that the change
is necessary in part because of how incredibly
common it is to take unsanitized user input from
the internet and pass it directly to int.
On the other side are authors and users
of libraries that use big numbers,
meaning this is probably going to
hit math libraries the hardest.
This may complicate things for their users and,
of course, now the code that they've
already put out there is broken.
Some in this camp have argued that doing
anything with unsanitized user input is
already a vulnerability waiting to happen,
so it should really be up to vulnerable APIs
to sanitize their inputs, not the Python
language to limit how numbers work.
Others are confused why we're using
these N^2 algorithm, when there are
known faster algorithms readily available.
Potentially, switching to faster algorithms could
make the denial of service infeasible, eliminating
the need for the digit limit at all.
And then, of course, there are a large number of
people that are perfectly fine with the change
as they are most likely not affected by it,
but just upset by the lack of transparency or
opportunity to have their opinions considered
and to potentially prepare for the break.
Regardless of how this issue pans out,
the core dev team did apologize for
the lack of transparency on the issue,
although it is sometimes necessary for
security vulnerabilities.
And they are welcoming
further discussion on the issue.
If you have an opinion on the matter,
especially if you are affected by the change, the
correct place to respectfully voice your opinion
is the Python discourse, linked below.
Please keep your suggestions and criticism
constructive and don't use
the discourse to rant.
And that's where I pass it off to you.
What do you think about this breaking change?
Is protecting vulnerable APIs that you or I
may unknowingly be using every day worth it?
Even if that means some math
libraries are broken?
Or should vulnerable code be on
the hook to sanitize its inputs?
Don't forget to subscribe,
and I'll see you next time.
As always, thank you to my Patrons
and donors for supporting me.